[Music]
outside of minimizing physical stuff
what have you learned so far about
minimizing the internal elements of life
like stress depression and worry
so to worry about something is simply
to pray for something bad to happen in
the future
yeah this question makes me think about
how we've how i already talked about why
worrying is kind of pointless
um
i mean
to worry is a symptom
so if you're worrying about something i
can look at it and
like say okay is this a symptom of
something i need to uh bring my
attention or my resources towards
or
is it something i can't control and if
it's something i can't control then i
have certainly learned to declutter that
that worry yeah so stress is often a
sign
that something is
amiss
now usually that something has to do
with our expectations
there are two types of fear there's a
real fear which is present in immediate
danger this is the only type of fear
that hunter-gatherers have like the
hadza or the maasai
if a bear breaks through that door
and comes in the room right now you and
i are gonna have real fear yes jordan
isn't he's gonna wrestle the bear to the
ground that's right
but you and i mere immortals he's just
waiting for that moment in his life
you look over he has a machete in his
hand
and someone's in there
and uh he takes off his mickey mouse
watch or whatever he's wearing today
and anyway and but
that's clear and present danger it makes
sense to have you there's a biological
impaired in fact there's something wrong
with you if you don't have
a fear response to that yeah there's
something actually wrong with your
biological
programming the way you are wired as a
human being because we are meant to have
fear in those situations yes the problem
we have is now all of a sudden we have
that same fear because oh no the house
side that i wanted to buy just went on
market and someone else put an offer on
it i'm terrified i'm worried no i'm not
going to get the thing that i really
want it's going to make me happy it's
going to make me content it's going to
make me more complete no it's not that's
a that's a chase
no wonder we get so stressed out because
we're chasing everything based on our
expectations
and
if we are chasing of course we're going
to be more stressed out
and so
the letting go of stress often has to do
with the stopping of
the chasing now use the word depression
here
we had
john dolone
at our houston event
earlier this year
and he talked about we only use two
words these days
it's
anxiety and depressed
and it's like oh yeah my uh my mom just
yelled at me i'm i'm depressed
my wife just left me i'm depressed my
boss yelled at me i'm depressed
like nah you're not really you're just
and
part of it has to do with the language
we're using like i've actually
experienced real depression
because all the autoimmune stuff i had
going on and the dysbiosis and the
parasite and the e coli poisoning that i
had it caused this disruption in in my
microbiome that caused significant real
chemical depression but most of us when
we say we're depressed
we're not talking about that we're
talking about i'm a little sad because
my girlfriend left me
so i'm depressed
i'm anxious because my 401k account
isn't performing the way i want it to
perform
is that really anxiety
or is it
tethered to an expectation i need this
to perform this way i need this person
in order to be happy in fact
even if it means making that person
miserable i need them so much
that i'm willing to make myself
miserable in order to retain them
that's not happiness
that is that's gonna cause anxiety
stress
discontent and the way to clutter the
declutter those isn't to declutter the
stress it's to declutter our
expectations that are causing the stress
causing the so-called depression causing
the worry in our lives because if we
don't
worry
if we let go of the worry
we have nothing to worry about
[Music]
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free